[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيه بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي
من بدايه القرن التاسع عشر وحتى يومنا هذا
بامكاننا القول انه في اغلب الدول
المتقدمه طبيا فانه متوسط عمر الانسان
ازداد تقريبا ثلاثه شهور كل سنه ففي مراحل
عيش الانسان في الماضي كانت فرص النجاه او
التقدم بالعمر ما بتتعدل 50% لحتى نتمكن
انه نوصل لسن العشرين سنه فقط هذا كله
بالطبع كان مرتبط باحتمالات الموت نتيجه
للامراض المعديه الساريه والمجاعات
والحروب والحوادث بشتى اشكالها
لكن بفضل التقدم الطبي تمكن البشر من
الوصول لحلول وعلاجات للتعامل مع هاي
الامراض او على الاقل تجنبها والنتيجه
كانت ربما اعظم انجازات بني ادم فقد تمكنا
من اطاله عمر الانسان مما متوسط اربعين
سنه الى ما يقرب الثمانين الان وهذا طبعا
جعل سبب واحد يتفوق على كل سيناريوهات
الموت المختلفه اللي ذكرتها سابقا ليتربى
على عرش اسباب الموت الاكثر انتشارا وهو
الشيخوخه
الشيخوخه هذه هي سبب موت ثلثي عرقنا
البشري الاحصاءات بتشير الى انه هناك
100,000 حاله وفاه يوميا بسببها طبعا هذا
ما بيعني انه هذا العدد من الناس بتموت في
سريرها اثناء نومها لكنه ايضا بيتضمن
الموت جراء امراض مرتبطه بالشيخوخه مثل
امراض القلب والسرطانات اللهم عافنا وكمان
الخرف وكتير من الامراض الاخرى
احنا نعلم بدون شك انه التدخين وقله
ممارسه الرياضه والتغذيه السيئه بتزيد من
احتمالات الاصابه بالامراض لكن اللافت انه
هذه الاسباب تعد صغيره جدا تخيلوا مقارنه
بالشيخوخه
المضحك المحزن هون طبعا هو انه كما هو
متوقع فانه الاثرياء هم الاكثر اهتماما
باطاله العمر
ويبدو لي انه الفقراء ما بيمانعوا مغادره
هاي الدنيا فمن اشهر من يستثمر وبشراسه في
هاي العلوم وتكنولوجياتها اناس مثلا مؤسس
امازون وكمان
وهناك كبرى شركات تكنولوجيا مثلا جوجل
اللي استثمرت في البحوث الطبيه مئات
الملايين عن طريق احد مؤسسيها لاريسن
ولهون فهاي كلها امور متوقعه يعني بقصد
الاستثمار لكن انه يقوم احد مجانين
سيليكون فالي باختيار نفسه كفار تجارب فهي
بصراحه ما كانت متوقعه ابدا
وقبل ما نتابع متابعينا الكرام سرد القصه
فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع بحب ارحب بضيفي
في الاستوديو الدكتور فراس الربيعي
استشاري طب الاسره وامراض كبار السن اهلا
وسهلا فيك دكتور معنا في كلام منطقي
انه ابلش معك بسؤال عام بدايه قبل ما
نتابع الحديث بشكل تفصيلي هل فعلا احنا
قادرين على عكس الشيخوخه والتقدم بالسن هل
اعضائنا الداخليه مش بس عم نحكي عن شكلنا
الخارجي من جوده البشره
هذه يعني في الها كتير علاجات هاي الايام
حتى عم بيستخدموها صغار السن مش بس كبار
السن ولكن مثلا عضله القلب هل هي قادره
على انها تنبض الى ما لا نهايه
اذا كان لم يكن هناك اي تاثير سلبي عليها
عظامنا
الغضاريف في في المفاصل مثلا هل هي قادره
على ذلك رغم انه حتى في الطبيعه في عوامل
النحت والتعريه فمن المؤكد انه داخل جسمنا
فيه نوعا من عوامل النحت والتعريه بفعل
الزمن والسنين
بعدين بنوصل الى مرحله عندي تلف اكثر من
التبديل ادخل في مرحله نقول عليه الشيخوخه
او الامراض وهاي التفاصيل بشكل عام فهي
هذا المبدا
مساله التلف اللي يصيب خلايانا بالضبط اكو
العوامل اللي هي بس مجرد العمل والنشاط
العادي اوكي من اني اتحرك من اتنفس من كذا
طبعا اكو خلايا تتلف وكو خلايا ذات تتجدد
في نفس الوقت بعدين تدخل عوامل اخرى
امراض سوء تغذيه سموم تدخين وخلاف اسلوب
حياه غير صحي بالضبط ايضا تاثر لي على
خلايا الجسم اكيد مئه بالمئه فهذه الفكره
هي من عندها فاذا اني انتبهت على مساله
التجديد
ووفرت لها الشروط او المقومات للاستمرار
فاكيد اقدر احافظ على اعضاء الداخليه
سليمه
بعد مساله اطاله العمر او لا يعني
مش المفروض بايديفولت زي ما بقولوا اذا
حفظنا على هذه الاعضاء سليمه
وتتجدد هذا يعني اطاله العمر بطريقه غير
مباشره بطريقه غير مباشره بالضبط
تدخل في هذه العوامل الاخرى هي الجينات
الجينات هي اللي تسوي تركيبتنا اني كانسان
جيناتي صح احنا
نتشارك انا واياك ومع البشر جميعا بس
ترتيب هذه الجينات مالتي يختلف عن ترتيب
الجينات اللي عندك فكل واحد اله مواصفاته
الخاصه
نعرف احنا الان
بعدنا ما مواصلين الى كل العلم الكافي بس
انه في جينات السبب انها امراض
جيد في حاليا يعني
حظ او العائله والزيجات
وهي نفس العمليه انت الطبيعه تختار الافضل
بالطبيعه مثلا
طبيعي بالضبط احنا البشر نمارسها بس بدون
قصد شخص يريد يتزوج يبحث عن امراه يجوز
عدى شويه طول عائلتها سليمين ما عدا امراض
معينه فقط حتى يضمن اطفاله يكونون افضل او
سليمين حاليا احنا نقوم بفحوصات قبل
الزواج للتاكد من عدم وجود مثلا 30 ما عدم
وجود امراض انتقاليه حتى
نعطي فرصه اكثر انه اطفال اصحاء يعني
ولكن ما ستنجب فرص افضل
للحياه فهي فاحنا بنسوي عمليه انتخاب
الطبيعي بطريقه غير مباشره يعني فهي هاي
احنا كل ما يكون جيناتي جيده كل ما
احتماليه الحدود الاشياء الجيده هي افضل
يعني كفرص بس ايضا لحظه الحمل ماذا تعرضت
له الام
الزكام او
كان بسيط خلفي جسمها
طبعا اللي يسوي لي طفرات الوراثيه فتشوفين
الام والاب من تفحصين جيناتهم سليمين بس
هاي الطفره وراثيه موجوده عند الطفل
حدثت نتيجه الى شخصيا وليس لي
في دراسه تقول انه الطفرات عند الانسان
معظم الاحيان السلبيه وليست ايجابيه عكس
الطفرات مثلا عند الحيوانات لا يكونون
افضل يصير اقوى في المقاومه البشر لا
يصيروا المرض او اضعف او شيء بس يعني
فيعني من الناحيه النظريه دكتور نقدر نعكس
التقدم في السن نقدر نعيش نظريا الى ما لا
نهايه طبعا الاعمار بيد الله والموت على
الجميع حق
ولكن نظريا طبيا على الاقل هذا هو طيب
خليني اسمح لي دكتور تبقى معي راح اكمل
سرد القصه للاعزائي المتابعين وبنرجع
نتحدث الان عمليا جيد شو هو الواقع
الحديث هون عما اسماه الاعلام باكثر شخص
يفحص في التاريخ البشري واللي هو براين
جونسون يمكن كتير منكم شفتوا اخبار عنه في
الفتره الاخيره والايام الاخيره على
السوشيال ميديا وعلى الاخبار كمان
ويعني الناس بعض الناس سمتوا بالمجنون
واخرين سموه بالعقري هذا كله بيعتمد على
كيف انتم بتطلعوا على الموضوع لكن مراحل
هوسو بايجاد ما نسميه نافوره الحياه او
نافوره الشباب واكسير الحياه اخذوا الى
حدود مجنونه
مش راح اطول عليكم بالتفاصيل لكن راح
اعطيكم لمحه بسيطه عن روتينو اليومي براين
بينام ما بين ثمانيه الى تسع ساعات يوميا
وتمارين الرياضيه يوميه بدون ايام راحه
نهائيا وكل يوم بمارس الرياضه لمده 67
دقيقه بالتحديد هو بتناول ما متوسط 100
حبه دواء او مكمل غذائي يوميا لمختلف
اعضاء جسمه وبيخضع العلاجات بالليزر
لبشرته اسبوعيا وهو طبعا ما بياكل مثلنا
ابدا طعام عباره عن مكونات عضويه اختيرت
بعنايه لحتى تلاقم تكوينه الجسماني تحديدا
وبيقوم بضربها في الخلاط وبياكلها بالرغم
من انه طعمها غريب جدا لدرجه انه احد
الصحفيين لاجراء معه مقابله مؤخرا بقول
انه قدم له كوب من نفس هذا الطعام وانه
اضطر مسكين الصحفي يضطر انه يستلقي على
الارض ليمنع شعوره بالغثيان جراء غرابه
طعم هاي الخلطه على كل حال براين موظف في
منزله 30 طبيب بيتابعوا علامات او مؤشرات
جسده الحيويه ساعه بساعه واستثمر في
الطابق الثاني من منزله ما وصفه هذا
الصحفي بانه حلم اطباء كبرى المؤسسات
الطبيه من حيث الاجهزه والتكنولوجيات
المستخدمه
اما اذا كان عندكم فضول لمعرفه الكلفه لكل
هذا طيب راح اخبركم كل هذا المهرجان
بيكلفوا ما يقرب من مليونين وربع دولار
بالسنه بس
براين تمكن حتى الان من ارجاع زمن جسده
ومؤشراته الحيويه ما يقرب من خمس سنوات
وهو طبعا هاي التجربه بادئها من سنتين
وبقول لا يهمني ما الكلفه او مقدار الالم
الذي علي تحمله او حتى كمل انتقادات اللام
متناهيه فانا اليوم كل ما كنت اتمنى ان
اكون
بضيف براين انه راح يواظب على علاجه حتى
تتساوى علامات جسمه الحيويه تخيلوا او
مؤشرات جسمه مع مؤشرات جسم ابنه اللي عمره
15 سنه فقط
ولله في خلقه شؤون بصراحه الغريب انه ربما
من عشرين سنه مضت كان حلم الطب هو ابطاء
عمليه التقدم في السن لكن في ايامنا هاي
مع القفزات الضوئيه للتقدم الطبي
وتكنولوجي فانه الهدف تغير وتطور زي ما
راينا الى عكس التقدم في السن مش بس
ابطائه وتاخيره براين بيرفض حتى اللحظه
مشاركه نتائج تجربته مع العالم لاسباب هو
فقط بيعرفها فاذا تبادر لاذهانكم فكره انه
ممكن يكون نصاب زي ما خطرت في بالي انا
فاعذروني لاني راح اخيب ظنكم تماما مثل ما
خاب ظني
فبينما كنت احاول توسيع دائره بحثي هذا
وصلت الى مقال طبي حديث جدا على موقع
ساينس فوكس المتخصص المقال بشير الى
مجموعه من الباحثين بيسموا انفسهم
الخالدون
وهؤلاء كرسوا حياتهم المهنيه لاكتشاف طرق
جديده لاطاله عمر الانسان بهدف الوصول الى
الخلود حسب وصفهم المقال بيوصف الاساليب
المختلفه اللي بيتبعها هؤلاء احد اهم
اجزاء بحثهم بيتعلق ببيولوجيه التقدم في
السن واللي برايهم انه اذا ما نظرنا اليه
او للشيخوخه كمرض فيمكن ايجاد علاج له
بحثهم بخوض في علم الجينات وقواعد خلايا
الشيخوخه وبيعملوا على ايجاد وتطوير ادويه
بتستهدف الاسباب البيولوجيه للتقدم في
السن بالاضافه لمحاوله ايجاد طرق للحد من
الامراض المرتبطه بالشيخوخه واطاله مده
عمر الانسان الخالي من الامراض
احد هذه الادويه اللي بتم تطويرها الان
يسمى سينولاتيك
وبيستهدف هذا الدواء الخلايا العجوزه
وبيتخلص منها وبقلل كمان من الالتهابات
وبيحسن عمل الانسجه
هناك ايضا علاج اخر يسمى
نيكاتينومايد
اسمه صعب شوي صعب يشار اليه بان اي دي بلس
وهو معزز لخلايا معينه مهمه مرتبطه بتراجع
انتاجها وافرازها مع التقدم بالعمر
نفس المقال بناقش المحاسن والمساوئ
المحتمله كمان لفكره اطاله عمر الانسان
فمن جهه يمكن انه يقودنا الى مرحله ترتفع
فيها سنين العيش للبشر بحيث نكون اكثر صحه
واكثر وعيا ونستخدم خبراتنا المتراكمه
لخير الانسانيه
ولكن على النقيض فانه نفس الفكره رح تعني
اقتضاض الارض اكثر مما هي مكتظه اصلا
والنزاع على الموارد المتوفره من قبل
اعداد اكبر بكثير من البشر وتاثيرات هاي
الفكره اقتصاديا والتغيرات المجتمعيه
والاخلاقيه المصاحبه لالها
عموما فكره المقال الاساسيه هي القاء
الضوء على التقدم المثير اللي بقوم فيها
هؤلاء الخالدون وامثالهم من الباحثين
والعلماء في حقل التقدم العلمي لكن ستظل
فكره هزيمه الموت او الالتفاف عليه فكره
نظريه هذا ما بقلل من اهميه بحوثهم اثناء
محاولتهم الوصول لهدفهم المنشود سواء كنت
تتفق مع الفكره ام لا والمقال لم ينسى
ايضا اهميه الاشاره الى الجانب الاخلاقي
من هذه الفكره مع ضروره التاكد من انه اي
انجاز راح يتم استخدامه بطريقه اخلاقيه
وعادله ما رح تحابي من يقدر على دفع الثمن
على حساب من لا يقدر
طيب نرجع لموضوعنا دكتور اذا
حكينا نظريا انه هذا الكلام
ممتاز وفعلا يعني هذا ما ينصح به الاطباء
انه يعيش حياه اسلوب حياه صحي كل اكل صحي
ابتعد عن التدخين بتاعنا ابتعد عن كل ما
هو سيء لجسدك وستطيل عمرك ستعيش اكثر
هذه يعني ربما هذه من نواميس الحياه يعني
وتقديرات الله سبحانه وتعالى ولكن في مثلا
هذه القصه اللي كنا عم نحكي عنها تجربه
بلوك اللي عم بيعملها اكثر رجل يفحص في
التاريخ هيك سمته السوشيال ميديا وكل
وسائل الاعلام اللي هو براين جونسون طبعا
هذا الشخص عماله بيصرف حوالي مليونين
مليونين اثنين مليونين وربع دولار بالسنه
عشان هذا الهدف وهو التجربه تبعته لها
سنتين تقريبا
ولكن يعني الاشياء اللي عماله بيضطر انه
يعملها لحتى يعني يكون ملتزم بهذا الروتين
الصحي لحتى يقدر يعكس تقدم السن عمره هو
قدر الحقيقه بخمس سنوات هو عمره 45 ولكن
كل مؤشرات جسده
وعمر اعضاءه الداخليه تشير انه في
الاربعين
اشياء غير عمليه نهائيا يعني كيف عم بياكل
وكيف بعيش وكيف ينام وكيف بيلعب رياضه
وعامل الطابق الثاني من منزله محوله
لمستشفى بيحلم فيه كبار المستشفيات تحلم
لي مثل هاي الاجهزه الموجوده
الليزر اللي بضطر يتعرض له علشان صحه
بشرته وتجديد الخلايا اللي فيها هذا اشي
مستحيل احنا نقدر نعمله
يعني هل بضل الموضوع ضرب من الخيال حتى
وان كان نظريا ممكن تطبيقه ولكن مش عملي
نهائيا
مثل الاشياء التي يقوم بها هي اشياء
معروفه بس هو خلينا نقول رتبها على اساس
حاجه جسمه هو كانسان
مشكلتنا بهاي الاشياء احنا
نعرض هاي الاسئله كاطباء
ما دام ما عندي ريفرس او مرجع او دراسه
منشوره وطبعا عمليه
نشر الدراسات فيها كثير ضوابط
العدد النماذج الماخوذه كيفيه اجراء
الدراسه هل هي دراسه يسموها
للدراسه العمياء انه تعطيني دواء ومتى
تكتبين عليه دواء وقسم تعطيهم ايضا الدواء
بس او يكون كبسوله فيها سكر وقسم ما
تعطيهم الدواء بالضبط وبعدين من تخلصين
الارقام تفتحين
انه هذا الشخص اخذ الدواء وهذا ما اخذ
الدواء وهكذا حتى تكون دراسه محايده
حاليا احنا بس لناخذ معلومات من هذا الشخص
وحتى هو رافض انه يشارك يعني كل تفاصيل
نتائج التجربه
وهذا نتكلم عن انسان واحد ومش قبل شويه
تكلمنا عن الجينات زين الجينات هذا
الشيء جيد جدا يعني هو بيتحدث عن اشياء
كتير دقيقه مثل مثلا انه هو بحاجه
لسبعه وستين او بمارس الرياضه لسبعه وستين
دقيقه تحديدا كل يوم بدون اي يوم راحه هذا
جيد اني اقدر هسه بدنا ناخذ حضرتك بالضبط
كل يوم اسوي تحاليل احتاج مبدئيا الى
يسموها
تحليل في عندي تحاليل بحر من التحاليل وكل
شيء اقدر افحصه مو كل شيء بس يعني
الامكانات اللي عندي مثلا
اتكلم عن الغده الدرقيه على سبيل المثال
ادنى لها ثلاث تحاليل اقدر اشوف نشاط غده
الدرقيه سوينا التحليل اليوم جيد بعدين
اقول لك اعملي رياضه اعيد التحليل بعد
الظهر وثاني يوم ما تعملي رياضه نسوي
التحليل بعد الظهر وهكذا واقارن الارقام
واسالك
اي فتره حسيتي بيها انت افضل شيء كان في
هاي الساعه او هاي الساعه او هاي الساعه
فحددت بالنسبه لي انه احتاج هذا الرقم من
الغده الدرقيه الى ستراويه في هذه اللحظه
اللي شعرت بيها بافضل شيء
حافظ عليه عن طريق اشوف شركه سويت رياضه
كم دقيقه كذا ماذا اكلت شنو نظام الغذائي
كذا كذا كذا كذا فعرفت الاشياء المناسبه
الى الغده الدرقيه الى ست راويه يعني يعني
هذه التجربه لا يمكن تعميمها معنى ذلك بس
هو مسميها يعني الخريطه الاوليه
تجربه الخريطه الاوليه طب معنى ذلك هي
يعني هذا اشي سيفيده ما راح يفيدنا يعني
تجربته لا يمكن تعميمها اساس التجربه يفيد
احنا قلنا اللي هو
الاكل الصحي هذا واحد اثنين الابتعاد عن
السموم عكس
التقدم في السن والحفاظ ونفس الوقت
متى اعكس يعني لما يصير مشكله بس من يجيني
خلينا نقول شاب عمره 30 سنه وسويت له
فحوصات وكل شيء طلع عنده سليم فما احتاج
اعكس شي بس احافظ احتاج انا احافظ على
لديه الان يجيني شخص نفسه هو عمره 30 سنه
بس لايف ستايل عنده سيء عنده السمنه عنده
زياده في الكوليسترول عنده زياده في سكري
الدم لا اعكسها انه انقص وزن تسوي حركه
وقف دخان اسوي التحاليل ترجع عندي الى
المستوى الطبيعي
مشكلتنا من نقول كلمه طبيعي
ما هو الطبيعي
اللي جسمي يختلف عن الطبيعي اللي جسمك
والطبيعي لجسمك يختلف عن الطبيعي الى جسم
اختك وهكذا
فاحنا مبدئيا انا افضل كلمه المستقر
المستقر هو الشيء الذي يقوم بدوره المطلوب
من عنده
جيد فهنانه تبقى في الفروقات بالنسبه لنا
مثل ما قلنا اقدر ارجع السكري الى الطبيعي
بدون ادويه لو كان سببه هو السمنه
وغير اشياء بس لو كان السكري سببت تلف في
البنكرياس لا ما اقدر ارجعه لاحظت
الانسولين كحقن يعني معنى ذلك بانه مش
الكل بقدر يعكس تقدم العمر عنده على حسب
وضعه
اذا ما عنده اي امراض مزمنه يعني هذا ممكن
او على الاقل يحافظ على صحته وعلى شبابه
طب شو هي الطرق هل هل عن جد هي فقط هاي
النصائح اللي بنسمعها من كل طبيب بغض
النظر عن تخصصه وحتى بنسمعها من كل متخصص
باي مجال على السوشيال ميديا الاكل الصحي
الرياضه المش عارف ايش عن جد هي هاي فقط
ولا في اشياء اعمق واعقد من هيك بكثير وفي
اعمق واعقد بكثير جسم الانسان معقد جدا في
لحد الان تفاصيل ما عندنا معلومات عنها
مثال ما متاكد اي سنه بس احتمال 2014
منحت جائزه نوبل اللي دكتور لاكتشافه وليس
اختراعه اكتشافه هو موجود بروتين موجود في
جسم الانسان هذا البروتين وظيفته نقل
خليه في عينك طلبت ماده معينه تنسى
الاشاره الى هذا البروتين يجيب لها الماده
ويسلمها للخليل جيد لماذا اعطي جائزه نوبل
مو عشان اكتشف هذا البروتين ولكن شافوا
انه في احتمال تطبيقات على المستقبل اظن
البروتين اللي لازم ياخذ جائزه
فقالوا انه مثلا عندنا التهاب بكتيري في
الخد زين ليش انطي مضاد حيوي اخلي يدخل
على كل جسم الانسان من راسه الى اخمص
القدم
اتصل بالبروتين اقول لها هل انت وديه الى
هذا المكان فبدل ما اعطيك جرعه 500
مليجرام اعطي الجرعه زيرو بوينت 5
اعتقد انه هذا ما يسمى بالانجليزي
العلاجات
التي تستهدف مش كل الجسم ولكن مواضع الخلق
طيب معنى ذلك هل يمكن العمل على
عكس التقدم بالعمر او المحافظه على صحه
الاعضاء كل عضو على حده ام انه زي ما كل
اعضاء الجسم مترابطه ببعضها البعض احنا
بنشتغل على
ما هو كامل منها وليس ما هو مجزر صحيح لان
احنا كل اعضاء جسمنا متصله مع بعض
ووحده تخاطب الثانيه وتطلب اشياء مثلا من
تقومين بنشاط رياضي لماذا القلب يسرع من
دقات القلب لبحث كميه اكسجين اكثر الى
العضلات حتى ياخذ الفضلات من العضلات
ويبعثها الى الكليتين على سبيل المثال ففي
عمليه تخاطب بين اعضائنا ولكن بنفس الوقت
اعضانا انانيين من توصل مرحله انه اني او
غيري لا اقول لك اني
زي الانسان نفسه
للقلب اخر شيء من في مراحل الاخيره يبدا
يضخ الدم فقط لنفسه
ما يهمني بعد اعضاء اخرى اذا الدم عم يوصل
اصابع الرجلين او لاهميه
لازم احافظ على نفسي يعني هنا تجي مساله
العكس مثلا اذا تكلمنا عن
شخص خلونا نقول
اجا للطبيب وطلب فحص الكوليسترول لا باس
سويت لفحص على الارقام اللي عندنا طلع انه
ارقامها عاليه جيد كيف اتصرف مع هذا الشخص
جيد اسال تاريخ عائلتك عندك مشاكل بالقلب
الشرايين كذا كذا ما هي الامور التي
تسويها انت واحد اثنين ثلاثه اكتشفنا انه
هذا الانسان سليم مدى يمارس اي شيء خطا
يقدر ياثر لي على مستوى الكوليسترول بس
هذا ايضا اني انتبه انه هل في احتماليه
بدات عند تصلب شرايين القلب نعم وارد جيد
ابعث على طبيع القلب بست فحص جهاد القلب
احتمال يطلع عندي طبيعي كانت نسبه تصلب
الشرايين قليله
فحص الاخر انظمه ملونه واخذ له صور اقدر
اشوف اذا كان في تضيق في الشريان جيد
اكتشفت في تضيق مثلا 40% وثلاثين بالمئه
جيد بدات عمليه تلف في خلاء بشرايين القلب
جيد الان كيف اعالج هذا احاول اخفض له
مستوى الكوليسترول عن طريق ادويه عن طريق
لايف ستايل يعني اي اجراء معين جيد اطلب
منه ان يبدي مايس رياضه حتى يزيد من نشاط
البدني عنده من نفس الوقت حي جيد يزيد لي
من نشاط القلب جيد
ماذا يحدث بعد ذلك هنا ما عندي دراسات
محدده اقدر اقول انه اقدر اوقف عمليه
تصلب الشرايين بهاي الاجراءات بس انه
اعكسها وارجع الشريان الى وضع الطبيعي ما
عندي هاي معنى ذلك عكس الشيخوخه لما نحكي
او عكس التقدم
في المفهوم
كل طبق عندما تكون انت انسان تتمتع بصحه
جيده ما عندك مشاكل معينه فبالتالي سيعمل
يعني
كل العلاجات او الطرق لي عكس الشيخوخه
ستعمل على جسدك كاملا متكاملا لانه ما
عندك اي اعضاء تشكو من اي مشكله معينه صعب
حلها طيب اذا لو رجعنا دكتور لموضوع وهاي
التجربه هو هدفه بيقول انه يعني يواظب على
هذه التجربه ويستمر فيها لغايه ما يوصل
عمر اعضائه او مؤشراته الحيويه الداخليه
تصير تضاهي وتساوي مؤشرات الحيويه تبعت
ابنه اللي عمره 15 سنه
ما معنى ذلك هل نقدر نضلنا نصغر نصغر ايش
طب بالاخر يعني بنرجع لارحام امهاتنا
اصغر بالعمر يعني لغايه متى هاي الجواب
على سؤال حيكون مثل مطرقه الى مساله النمو
الطفل الى ان يوصل مرحله البلوغ اللي هي
خلينا نقول المرحله
الاستقرار الفتره الذهبيه خلينا نقول في
اعمارنا من اي اعمار هي قلت انت من البلوغ
لغايه ماذا
للحين ما تبدا يصير عندنا اكثر من التبديل
فنبدا ندخل في مرحله 36 انا قريت دراسه
تتحدث عن انه هذا هو العمر فيعني عندك 20
سنه ذهبيه تقريبا من 16 لسته وتلاتين ولا
ولا مش مش دقيق فاحنا عندنا مرحله البلوغ
احنا مرحله نحكي على مرحله البلوغ الذهني
على سبيل المثال كدماغ نحكي بعمر الاربعين
على حسب المثال الفكر عندنا يستقر حتى انت
الاسامي بالعربيه مثلا يعني اني شاب الى
عمر 39
اربعين اصير رجل
وبعدين بصير كاهل وعجوز
فالعوده نصغر لغايه ما نصل الى
اعضائي في حاله عمل تام وما فيها اي مشاكل
هنا تبقى هي المساله مثل ما قلنا انه
قابليات قلبك يختلف عن قابليات قلبي فاحنا
ما هو الحد هل نعتبر مثلا اذا كان بامكاني
ان اصعد عشر طوابق
نحط في هذا اصعد عشر طوابق بدون ما اشعر
بالتعب انه هذا البيرفكت هذا الافضل اداء
قلبي يقدر يعمله زين اقدر ادفع اكثر
واسويها 12 طابق
لاحظنا بالطب مثلا
الرياضات المحترفين في بعض الاحيان ضاره
للجسم وليست نافعه هذه الاكستريم اللي
بتكون يعني
على سبيل المثال الانسان ما مطلوب من عنده
ان يركض 40 كيلو متر او اثنين واربعين
كيلو متر ما اعتقدش انه احنا صممنا لذلك
يعني
في ناس اللي بعض النساء اللي يركضون هاي
المسافات الطويله تقطعهم الدوره الشهريه
نتيجه زياده هرمون الذكوره في جسمهم
نتيجه نتيجه الرياضه اللي تصير فهذا يسوي
لها مشاكل
ما خدم صح عضلاته قويه مفاصل قويه ولكن
عظامها صارت رقيقه نتيجه
قبل هيك طيب اذا اذا كان انه احنا فعلا
نقدر يعني
نعكس تقدم في السن ونرجع على الاقل الامر
اللي نضجنا فيه واكتمل نمونا في اللي هو
مرحله المراهقه هل معنى ذلك بانه احنا عن
جد فعلا بنقدر نزيد متوسط اعمار البشريه
بهل قفزات الكبيره لانه
يعني وانا اورثت هذا الكلام في نصي بانه
من تقريبا مع بدايه القرن الثامن عشر يعني
1700 وكذا كان متوسط الاعمار 40 سنه
احنا قدرنا نرفعها لحوالي 80 سنه الان
بقديش بحوالي 300 سنه بخلاف الفتره 300
سنه هل احنا مع هذا التقدم الطبي
والتكنولوجي الكبير خلال كمان 20 او 30
سنه بنقدر نرفع متوسط الاعمار لنصير
العادي انه احنا نموت على الميه ولا 120
هل هذا ممكن
بناء على المعلومات اللي متوفره عندنا
المفروض ممكن نفس هذا المبدا لا مو نظريا
عمليا موجوده من حشيش على دوله السويد
اللي انا كنت عايش فيها
[موسيقى]
وعشت فيها واشتغلت لمده 14 سنه
فمن ترجعين الى
الاحصاءات اللي عندهم متوسطه اعمارهم
زاد خلال اخر مئه سنه
الاعمال بحدود
احكي لك على العراق لا من تركت العراق
بالالفين واحد كان معدل الاعمار 61 للرجال
63 للنساء
بعد حدوث المشاكل بالعراق انخفض معدل
الاعمار الى 59
جيد نفس التجارب صارت مع
اليابانيين اللي عايشين في امريكا
جيناتهم يابانيه ولكن من غيره البيئه اللي
حواليهم كانوا يصيبون بامراض ما يصابون
فيها في اليابان ولكن اصيب الامراض اللي
صار بها الامريكي عشان اللايف
ستايلز بيتزا
فكثير متغيرات بس انه اطاله عمر الانسان
نعم بارده صارت مثبوته علميا بناء سكان
محورها هو تحسين النظام الصحي
من ضمنها ايضا على سبيل المثال اللقاحات
احنا كنا نقيس تطور المجتمعات
بالوفيات الاطفال اقل من خمس سنوات
من ضمن الاشعه اللي كانت تموت الاطفال هو
فقط الاسهال
جفاف والطفل يموت صح او الحصبه او الجدري
بالضبط الاسهال تعال جيب محلول الاروع
فموي هذا الطفل عاش
لقاحات الحصبه لقاحات الشلل الاطفال
طبعا قله اللي وفيات
وقام الانسان يعيش فتره اطول وهكذا فكل
هاي الاجراءات الصحيه لدى نقوم بها ممكن
فعلا
اثناء او اطفالنا
اولادنا يعني العادي والمتوسط العمر مئه
سنه على طار المجتمعات من وصلت للسويد كان
عمري واحد ثلاثين
فبالعراق من عمرك 31 يعني وصلت
ادرس اللغه واكمل وكذا بعدين معدل الاعمار
خمسه صغير
طيب دكتور لو رجعنا
الكلمه اللي قلتها قبل شوي يعني كل شيء
بزيد عن حده ينقلب ضده هل تنطبق هاي
المقوله بالفعل على مساله عكس التقدم
بالسن يعني هل ممكن نوصل مرحله نصير نصاب
بامراض ما كناش نعرف عنها نهائيا او خلل
لم نشهده ولم نعهد ابدا في وظائف الجسم
نتيجه
لانه عمرنا صار يزيد لهذا للميه مثلا زي
ما صار مثلا وين كان الاوزايمرز ما حدش
كان يوثق انه في باركنسينز او في كانسر
اللي هو عاده بتزيد نسبته بشكل مهول عند
الرجال بعد سن معين ما كانوش يوصلوا
الرجال هاي السن كانوا يموتوا قبل يعني هل
ممكن انه فعلا تظهر لنا امراض هذه بتصير
بعد سن الميه بعد سن ال 200 فينقلب ضده
وارد جدا اقدر انطيش مثال
من خرجت من كليه الطب الخمسه وتسعين من
درسنا على خلل الجيني اللي يصيب احد
الجينات والتصابين بالداوند دروم جيد كان
معدل اعمارهم كاتبينه بالكتب انه 21 سنه
المصابين بهاي الحاله
بالضبط
لا وصل اعمارهم الى ستينات
جيد شو كانت اسباب الوفيات بالنسبه لهم من
ضمنها كان القلب سيصيبه مفشل في القلب
وكانت الالتهابات الرئويه الحاده كانت انه
ما يقدرون يقاوموها يموتون
لا نظام صاحب السويت جيد جدا
فحلوا هاي المشاكل وصلت اعمارهم الى 62
ضافوا حاليا على تشخيص الخرف او الزهايمر
يسموه خاص
باللي عندهم داونز
يعني من تشخيصاتهم انه الخرف اللي يصيب
فقط هاي المجموعه من الاشخاص نتيجه تقدمهم
بالعمر
بعدين ضفنا احنا مثلا باركنسون
اللي هو الخرف اللي يصاحب
اللي هو الاسم
وكل خرا في اللي سبب تصلب الشرايين
والجلطات الدماغيه واكو اللي يكون الاثنين
بين
الشرايين فاكيد احنا من تنطيل شي فده يبقى
يشتغل فتره اطول فتظهر عندنا اشياء ما
كانت ملحوظه عنا يعني فقط المستقبل
حيبلغني بهاي الاشياء قبل ما ننهي دكتور
والحقيقه الحديث لا يمل فعلا معك يعني انا
عارفه انه انا مش تخصصك ولكن يعني انا بحس
انه في تبعات وفي محاور اقتصاديه اجتماعيه
ونفسيه ايضا مرتبطه ب عكس التقدم بالعمر
وزياده متوسط اعمار البشريه بشكل عام كنا
عم نتحدث انا واياك قبل ما نبلش تسجيل في
الحلقه وحبيت انه نكمل هذاك الحوار كان في
عندك اراء الحقيقه يعني مثيره للاهتمام في
هذا الموضوع انا مثلا
بقلق بانه طيب لو صار في الوفيات اقل
بكثير من معدل الانجاب
او حتى معدل الانجاب استمر مثل ما هو لكن
عدد الوفيات انخفض لانه صار زاد متوسط
الاعمار وصارت الناس بصحه احسن طب هذا شو
راح يصير بالسكان بعدد السكان على هذا
الكوكب هل هذا الكوكب راح يتحمل
موارده راح تكفينا مثلا
يعني خلينا نقول موضوع الشاعر تدخل فيه
كثير عوامل
من ضمنها العوامل النفسيه اكيد
على مثال انه نحكي على العمل لو اني
بامكاني ان اعمل بدل ما عمر 65 او 60
انهي عملي ويعني
اروح للتقاعد عليه انه لا اشتغل لعمر
ثمانين زين ما هي فرصه الشخص اللي عمره
عشرين بالضبط اذا انا مازلت شغله منصبي
ومكاني نصير فيه بتنافس اكثر على الموارد
بالضبط النقطه الثانيه انه
تطور المجتمع الشخص اللي عمره 20 حتكون
عنده قابليات يجوز اني ليست لدي انه
امارسها فهو راح يمنعني من اداء عملي ولكن
اذا نحكي لا زين يعني اذا حافظت على نشاط
دماغي فبامكاني ان احصل على هذه القابليات
اللي عند الشخص اللي عمره 20 سنه هاي نقطه
زين اذا انا حايش هذا العمر الطويل لماذا
انجب اطفال اني كافي موجود بالحياه ليش
احاول احافظ على ديمومه الجنس
فبدل ما انجب اربع اطفال اسوي طفلين او
طفل واحد
فزين في لحظه من اللحظات كبار السن
حيحتاجون الى رعايه زين اذا ما في حد
يرعاهم من الاعمارهم الصغار زين منو
حيراعيهم
سبحان الله يعني تختل النواميس وتختل
الموازين ربما على كل حال ما هي كل كل زمن
بيجي بادواته
وبتحدياته
وبانجازاته ايضا
مثلا على المراه اذا طال عمرها وبعدت تحب
تدخل في مجال العمل فنجوز تغير اهتماماتهم
من الاسره الى العمل او تاجل عمليه
الانجاب لسن الخمسين على 60
ممكن ممكن على كل حال هينا احنا طبعا
التقدم الطبي والتكنولوجي بفاجئنا كل يوم
بشيء جديد طبعا يعني كله بحدث
تحسين حياه البشريه وانه نكون احنا افضل
ونتمتع بحياه اكثر رفاهيه واكثر
نجاحا خلينا نقول ان شاء الله يضل هذا هو
الهدف ان شاء الله وتكون نتائجه ايجابيه
للجميع عندي تعليق على مساله التطور مثلا
اذا نحكي على مساله الستريس
الهواتف الخلويه مثلا سابقا ان كنت اطلع
من البيت
اني اكون مفصول عن العالم
لحالي ما حد يقدر يتصل فيا الحين ما وصل
الى جهاز الهاتف الثابت في البيت او في اي
مكان ثاني فما فيش ضغوطات نفسيا بتجينا من
كل جانب يعني هسه انت الان كانك
احنا جالسين مع بعض
وجدتي مسج على تلفوني صار عندي من اللي
بعث المسج شو اللي يريد من عندي كيف
حجاوبه قمت افكر بهذا الموضوع بالرغم انه
اني المفروض مركز في شيء ثاني
بالضبط هو اهدافها كان مساعدتي ولكن لا
سويت لي مشاكل نحكي على السيارات مثلا
اوكي قبل انا كنت افطر امشي اداء امارس
حركه في عضلاتي ومفاصلي زين انا استخدمت
السياره زادت عندي السمنه صح بس صرت اوصل
اسرع وصرت اقدر
وقت في الطريق بالضبط
فهنا نيجي كل شيء هو سيف ذو حدين وفعلا
خيروا الامور اوسطها ولازم يكون في توازن
بشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور فراس على وجودك
معنا في كلام منطقي وان شاء الله اكيد راح
يكون لقاءات اخرى في المستقبل
شكرا شكرا
في ختام حلقتنا
اخيرا من وجهه نظر فلسفيه فانه فكره هزيمه
الموت بتطرح من دون شك مئات الاسئله
الوجوديه مثل معنى او مغزى الحياه نفسها
ففريقنا الناس يؤمن بانه الموت هو جزء لا
يتجزا من الحياه وهو ما يعطي الحياه نفسها
معنى وهدف وفريق اخر ينظر له كمشكله
بانتظار حل وانه الخلود سيعود بفوائد
كثيره لعرقن البشري شخصيا انا بتسائل هل
يريد احد منا حقا انه يعيش ميه او 150 سنه
ما بعرف يمكن كل شخص فينا لازم يحاول يسال
هذا السؤال ويجاوب عليه
هذا كلام منطقي على العربية بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما بامان
باذن الله
[موسيقى]